Will the upcoming North-South summit at
Panmunjom usher in a new era of Korean
peace and denuclearization? Seoul's
Sunshine – or engagement-oriented –
government certainly seems to think so,
and there are many in America and
elsewhere who seem to agree – including
even president Donald Trump (at least
from time to time). But let's not break
out the champagne just yet. The first two
North-South summits in 2000 and 2007
were flat-out failures, at least for the
West. Despite Sunshine promises and
predictions at the time, they led neither
to denuclearization nor to peace. Why
exactly should we think a third summit
with a third ruler of the Kim family
regime will turn out differently? True
peace with the South would require
Pyongyang to recognize the right of the
South Korean state to exist. True
denuclearization would force the Kim
family regime to give up its quest for
unconditional unification of the whole
peninsula. The real existing North Korean
state cannot accept either of these
propositions. Seoul's illusions therefore
look to be on a collision course with
reality, and maybe Washington's, too. Stay
tuned. What do you think the outcome of
What do you think the outcome of
the summit will be? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.